[Music]
welcome everyone to brilliant minds bold
questions
a five-part virtual event series
exploring questions being addressed by
some of the world's top researchers
each of these talks pairs speakers and
moderators from across disciplines
sectors and the world to explore the
questions shaping our future
cfar is a canadian-based global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions facing science and humanity my
name is mark daly
i'm the vice president research at cfar
and it's my privilege today to introduce
you to cfar co-director
and corner fellow adrian owen and cephar
azrieli scholar
megan peters adrian is co-director
and coroner fellow in cfar's brain mind
and consciousness program and a
professor
at the university of western ontario in
london ontario
he's best known for his work assessing
consciousness of patients
in vegetative states using functional
magnetic resonance imaging and
electroencephalography
megan peters is a cfar israeli global
scholar in the brain mind and
consciousness program as well
and an assistant professor at the
university of california irvine
she draws on insights and approaches
from cognitive science
psychology computational neuroscience
and philosophy
to understand how brains process and
evaluate sensory information
she was the chair of the inaugural
neural match academy which i hope we'll
hear more about today
an online summer school for
computational neuroscientists started
during the covid19 pandemic
today megan and adrian ask what are the
optimal conditions for our brains how
much sleep do we need
what can covet 19 do to the brain and
how has the pandemic changed
neuroscience
today's session will be 30 minutes i
will ask our speakers questions and will
also be taking questions from all of you
today throughout the session
if you have a question please submit it
through the q a function at the bottom
of your screen
lastly this session is being recorded
and will be available
on the cfair website next week
first question for you adrian you've
been leading a project that's exploring
the impact of coven 19 on the brain
can you tell us a little bit about this
study and what you've learned so far
sure well uh thanks very much mark um
yes in june of last year uh june 2020 we
decided to
start longitudinally following uh a
group
of uh copied 19 survivors to try and
understand a little bit about
you know a word that's been banded
around a lot at the moment that's that's
brain fog
uh does it exist how long does it go on
for and exactly
what is it so uh we used uh well this is
a
i should say this is a collaboration
between my team at weston
rick schwartz and his group at
sunnybrook hospital in toronto
and david mennon from cambridge uk david
is also
a fellow of the cfa brain mind and
consciousness program
david's a neuro-intensivist and an
anesthesiologist
and what we did is we asked people who
were recovering from kovid 19 to log in
to a platform that's been developed in
my lab known as cambridge brain sciences
cambridge marine sciences allows you to
completely remotely it's entirely web
based uh you can assess things like
memory
concentration problem solving decision
making
it's great because of course you can
access anybody anywhere on the planet
because
it's all done remotely so we asked uh as
many survivors as we could reach
uh to log in tell us about their
experiences and also to perform
these cognitive assessments and we're
about to publish the
the data from the first uh group of
participants about 500 people
they've all had a positive coveted test
so we can be absolutely sure that
uh they have had coveted 19. uh and what
we're finding
i think is pretty interesting people
won't be surprised at this point i think
to learn that
we are seeing uh fairly uh profound
cognitive deficits
uh but one thing that's uh one nuance is
that this is not an across-the-board
problem it's not
every aspect of your cognition that is
going to be affected by cognition
by by code 19 i mean for example
speed of thinking how fast you can think
through problems seems to be very
severely affected as is
reasoning and problem solving but memory
is completely
unaffected and that's that's important
for us because it'll give us a few clues
about
perhaps which areas of the brain are
being affected because we can relate the
exact pattern of deficits to what we
know about
how these cognitive functions are are
carried out by the brain
the second i think really interesting
finding is that the cognitive deficits
that we're observing
are really tightly linked to the
physical
uh the physical experiences of the
disease the physical symptoms so the
worst
uh the worst your your uh physical
symptoms the word the worst
uh your cognitive symptoms are likely to
be too and the reason why that's
interesting
is that these cognitive impairments are
not related
to other aspects of of mental health so
we were detecting high levels of
depression and anxiety in our sample
but depression and anxiety doesn't seem
to be related
to uh to the pattern of cognitive
impairments that's really tied
quite tightly to the to the physical
impairment
and the third and final thing i'll say
about the results is you know we're
really interested in
in knowing are these temporary problems
are they going to go away in a few
months
are they permanent problems do they do
they actually stay stationary
perhaps forever or worst case scenario
do they get
worse over time it's too early
to say uh or to definite to definitively
answer this at this stage
uh because we need to continue to follow
this cohort for the rest of the year
but the the early findings show that
there's no relationship between the
deficits and how long ago you had your
positive covid test and that's
that is an indicator that
the deficits may not be getting better
over time of course
it may also mean that they're not
getting worse over time but
uh yeah and that's where we are at the
moment as i say we're about we're about
to publish the findings we're
we're really uh excited about the uh
what we've managed to achieve here
thank you so much adrian that that is
really fascinating set of preliminary
results
i'm going to ask you a really unfair
follow-up question because because i
i know you don't have the mechanistic
data but if
if you had to hypothesize what do you
think the underlying
mechanism of insult might be so i
i think there are two possibilities i
mean one
is an area that i've done a lot of work
in in the past and that is
indirect effects on the brain so you
know this is a respiratory disorder
but any any kind of respiratory problem
is going to interrupt
the oxygen supply to the brain and can
have if you like
secondary effects on brain function the
example i use
most frequently is is cardiac arrest
most people think of cardiac arrest
being a
heart problem but actually many of the
patients that i see
outside of pandemic times who have had
had so-called brain damage have had it
through
cardiac arrest the cardiac arrest
produces a an interruption of the oxygen
supply to the brain
and the brain gets damaged and this
could be this could be similar you have
a respiratory illness we know it's
affecting many organs
in the body as well as the lungs and
that could be having
secondary effects on the brain could be
and i think the jury is still out on
this second issue which is
well is it a direct is the virus
actually affecting
the brain directly and you know there
are a number of papers coming out at the
moment to suggest that that
that might be the case and i think until
uh it's gonna it's gonna require a
little bit more work and a few more
studies to
to know that but the indirect effects
are absolutely certain we've seen them
before we see them pretty much
in anybody that ends up in the icu uh
but for non-coveted 19 reasons we'll see
indirect effects on the brain but
who knows about the direct effects i
think we'll find out in the next few
months
thanks adrian i look forward to reading
the paper when it comes out
megan question for you i know you're
involved in
a whole lot of really exciting
initiatives and i wonder if i could ask
you sort of a meta question around that
what are some of the ways in which we as
scientists have reorganized our
our scientific approaches during the
pandemic
uh sure yeah and thanks for the question
and thanks for um for this opportunity
this is really
exciting um so i as you said i've been
involved in
building some of these kind of massive
online initiatives
uh because we don't have the opportunity
to meet in person anymore
and what's happened um is is this really
vast expansion of scientific networks in
a way that everyone is not only
tolerant of virtual connections but
actually welcomes them and that
everybody is virtual whether it's
someone who's
in your department who you would
normally share an office wall with
versus someone who's literally halfway
around the world
it's all the same now um and so what
this means is that um
i've seen this personally and i i know
that many people have seen this as well
we see this this really big expansion of
our scientific networks in a way that
actually
democratizes science in a very exciting
way
so one of the um one of the initiatives
that i've been
involved in is we last spring a little
under a year ago we founded this summer
school
called neuromatch academy it was a
spin-off of some of the virtual
conferences that neuromatch had already
been running
and this means that we can actually
change
online education and move away from
passively delivered moocs
um these massive online courses where
it's like here is all the content
go and just do it on your own and and we
we built this
course so that we could um we could
actually democratize the delivery of
education high quality education across
the world science without borders we all
say
you know we want to do science without
borders um and now
i think a positive silver lining that's
come out of covid is that we can do that
really effectively um kind of out of
necessity
and so i we
through through this initiative and also
through through the uh see if our brain
mind consciousness program
and so on but especially through
neuromatch um i've i've got science
friends now um and science collaborators
that i have never met in person
ever and um and yet i count them among
my closest colleagues and closest
collaborators through this
um and we're really excited to be able
to deliver this content to students
worldwide we've
uh last year we had about 2 000 students
participate
in this program uh for free or very very
cheap like a
completely waivable fee and it means
that we can
we can deliver this content to students
we can work together to deliver this
content to students that
would not otherwise have access to it
due to
economic barriers geopolitical barriers
all of these things that
before it was like if you wanted online
education you had
moocs as an opportunity and now um
and now we're trying to change that to
say if i'm delivering the content to my
students here at uc irvine virtually
from
this home office why not deliver it to
students across the globe
i love it that is a true truly
impressive that you were able to reach
2 000 uh students in in your first run
and i love that this is aimed at you
know our scientific youth
how did you scale so quickly so that you
could launch
with 2 000 people participating that's
amazing how did you do it
well um i'm really glad you asked that
because uh
you know as you said like i was the the
chair of the inaugural
inaugural neuromatch academy i was not
the only one there there were about 250
volunteer organizers plus another 200
plus
uh uh faculty mentor volunteers
and then we had an additional 190
teaching assistants
um who were able to deliver this content
so this was like
i mean the organizers crew was about as
big as the student body um and it was
something that
we all kind of counted this as our
coveted hobby a lot of people
you know maybe built their garden up or
that kind of thing and we'd like to joke
that we kind of built this
this summer school from scratch so um so
it was it was a huge group effort and
it's been
a real pleasure and honor to work with
some of these people all these people
um who are really passionate about
delivering this education
to people who would not otherwise have
access to it
they're really inspirational and the
amount of night and weekend and
lost sleep hours and everything that
everybody dedicated to make it happen is
just
truly remarkable megan thank you for
leading that that is a fantastic
initiative
adrian beyond providing additional
subjects for you to study as a scientist
how how has kovid affected you and the
the opportunities that you have as a
scientist
um well actually if it affected my lab
uh more or less immediately and
quite dramatically i mean outside of
covert times
as you mentioned in the introduction
what i do is i assess
brain injury uh typically in patients
who are
in the intensive care unit uh either
because they've had a traumatic brain
injury like a
a blow to the head or as i was saying
previously perhaps a cardiac arrest has
caused
secondary brain injury so of course as
soon as covid hit
um we were essentially locked out of the
icu
it was just too risky for me to send my
staff and students in to
you know to see patients in that sort of
environment and it's been very patchy
for
the whole year we've we've been allowed
back in a few times but
mostly uh we've been not able to do it
so really early and this is one of the
impetuses for our uh our
our coveted study which is that you know
i had no choice what i
regularly did was no longer possible uh
so i looked at what we had in the lab
and unfortunately we had this
uh cognitive assess assessment platform
cambridge brain sciences it's been
around now for
more than 10 years and in fact we have
more than 10 million pieces of data on
that more than 10 million
test scores so we already had something
which was sort of up and running
and was really good at testing people
out there
in the wild in the general population
we've done large studies of things like
sleep and iq and brain training in the
past so
we knew that we could easily reach
thousands of people
so we just switched and many people in
my lab you know stopped going into the
icu stop seeing patients and started to
work on the on the covid project
or other projects that we could do
virtually
and i think i think we were lucky
because you know we had this platform
and it was it was not developed to
uh to cope with uh you know assessment
uh neuropsychology psychological
assessment during during pandemic which
just happened to
lend itself beautifully to that exact
purpose so
we could get on actually since the
pandemic began we we've we've conducted
a number of studies not only the
the covid studies we've had studies
looking at the effects of exercise
the relationship between mental health
uh
components of the pandemic in general
and how that affects cognition
uh even you know things like
bilingualism we've been able to look at
so
actually in many ways my research
changed uh
it changed quite dramatically overnight
but it's it's continued
to uh it's it's continued uh without
you know many aspects without
interruption
i think that ability to pivot as
circumstances change is what defines
successful researchers you know you you
never get quite the question you were
expecting
yeah and and being able to adapt with
the the the techniques and the methods
that you have right you know you
if you suddenly find it you can't do one
thing well i've got the equipment i've
got the people we have the expertise can
we apply that to
a different problem and that's exactly
what what we managed to do
thank you gonna turn to some audience
questions now and continue to encourage
the audience please send in questions
we've got some
world-class experts here to answer them
for you
megan question for you why do you think
so many people were eager to volunteer
their time for neuro match
are you that persuasive so
um one of the other co-founders of
neuromatch conference and academy um
kind of hooked people in by saying it
won't be that much work it won't be much
work um which it turns out was
was completely false um but i think that
uh part of it is that especially towards
the beginning of the pandemic we were
all
really suddenly clawed away from our our
professional and social interactions and
there was a lot of
um at least from my perspective and
myself
we were all craving that social
interaction and that that ability to
actually like feel like we weren't just
stuck like just waiting for the pandemic
to end
um and so this is a a number of us who
started the academy had already been
involved in building
other non-profit ventures
other summer schools other educational
opportunities i mean
the founding board of directors is all
professors
and so this was something that we were
all passionate about
um and that we were not going to be able
to deliver in the traditional
way this that last summer um
and it turns out there were a lot of
other people who thought like us who
also had their summer schools their
educational programs their mentorship
opportunities kind of
cancelled at the last minute and we all
were asking ourselves
well gee what are we going to do with
our summers what are we going to do with
ourselves and
um if if anybody in the audience knows
anybody who's an academic you know that
we don't really do well with like
sitting on our hands and doing nothing
and so this was just something that i
think a lot of people believed in the
mission
and the vision and also the recognition
that this was an
opportunity to actually make an impact
beyond the coveted period
to change education for the better uh
kind of out of necessity now but
in a way that would endure
i i think you're very humble not to
mention this but i will for you
good leadership is absolutely essential
to harness that type of enthusiasm and
goodwill so congratulations to you
but it really was not me to your entire
team
of course the whole team yeah yeah
um for sure adrian very focused question
for you from the audience
do you see differences in effect based
on age and demographic data
when you look at the post-covered brain
that's great
uh it's a great question um and i mean
the answer is
is no and yes so uh sex no
um at least not only not any uh
systematic differences
age definitely yes and you know i've
mentioned already that the
the cognitive deficits are really
tightly coupled to the physical
impairment and of course
everybody knows that those people who
are older
um are generally having more severe
physical responses uh to coping 19
infection and that's often to do with
other comorbidities that people have
when they're
getting older so so yes um the
older you are not only the more
serious you're the physical consequences
of kobe 19
but also um you know the more impaired
cognitively patients tend to be
which is interesting because the exact
opposite is true of
mental health so as i said previously we
assessed anxiety and depression in our
cohort using
standardized measures of these things
and actually
anxiety and depression is more prevalent
in the younger
members of the group so again it's not
related to
cognition to memory decision making
problem solving
this is anxiety and depression but this
is occurring more
in the younger members of the group than
in the older members
thank you adrian question for both of
you
how has your research on brain health
and neuroscience affected your own
choices and behaviors
sleep brain training exercise
you know how how do you live your lives
knowing what you know about how the
brain works
i can i can start if you like um i i
so well sleep is a very good example so
in 2018
uh we did another of these uh very large
uh
public studies we had about 10 000
people report all of their sleeping
habits
and then they performed our cognitive
tests online and we have people from all
over the
all over the world uh and because we had
so many people we were really able to
tease apart all the sort of different
factors
that uh contribute to um
you know to your cognitive performance
following uh either good sleep or bad
sleep and
we found some really interesting facts
some aren't that surprising
like uh the optimal amount of sleep is
between seven and eight hours most
people won't be surprised
to hear that uh but we also found that
too much
sleep is as bad for you as too little
sleep
and that's you know interesting and a
novel finding that i don't i don't think
will be
um obvious to to everybody and certainly
since that study i have started
monitoring my sleep
uh very carefully i mean in multiple
ways and there were many other nuances
in the data about you know not only how
long you should sleep for but
um you know whether it should be whether
if your sleep is interrupted how that
affects you how sleep patterns change
as you get older so um yeah so i
monetized i
first had a fitbit now i have an apple
watch and i have uh various other
devices i watch my
sleep very carefully and i do try to get
my
eight hours no more no less every night
as often as i can
thanks adrian
i don't have a lot to say about sleep um
but i will say
because i don't actually study sleep i
study you know sensory metacognition
um but i will just say very briefly that
one of the things that we're finding
in um sensory metacognition this is
your ability to kind of monitor your own
perceptual decision making and your
your ability to see and your ability to
hear
is that we see all the way down even at
the sensory level that
people have confirmation biases
we used to think that maybe these were
only cognitive effects that
once you make a decision about um what
food you like or what political
candidate to vote for you're going to
seek out information that
that confirms your your beliefs and
we're starting to see that this actually
exists all the way down at the sensory
level
that once your brain makes a decision
about what you see or what you hear
that it evaluates evidence differently
and it seeks out evidence that confirms
that hypothesis
so i've tried to to incorporate that
even at the sensory but also at the the
metacog or the cognitive level into my
own science and my own life to say
really very focused in a very focused
way to
avoid those confirmation biases whenever
i can and to try to really seek out
information that disconfirms every
hypothesis that i've ever come up with
you've made yourself the perfect
scientist i'm trying
another question for you megan and
adrian you can tag on too if you'd like
uh how do you foresee that the end of
the pandemic
is going to affect the development of
science without borders
do you think we're going to fall back to
to what we were doing before
or do you think things like neural match
can persist
i think this is a really great question
and i think that it's a question that's
that's bigger than just neuromatch and
just my little corner of science too i
think it it applies to education it
applies to business
it applies to everything that we've all
become not only tolerant
of but actually seeking out virtual
connection
um and there are some bad things about
this which is now we're all in
information overload
and uh you feel like you have to go to
all the talks or you have to see all the
things and
even if it's at 4am for you because
that's when it was convenient in europe
or something
um so i think that there will be there
will have to be a
push towards better curation of content
uh finding what is relevant to you
um and there are some services that are
popping up that are starting to do this
to help you kind of discover
what is relevant to you and not just
have it be like go look on the internet
and then you'll find stuff that's
relevant to you
i do think that there is space for both
virtual connection
and in-person connection at scientific
conferences in education
and business we are missing all of the
spontaneous interactions right now
you never have a case where you just
bump into someone in the hallway and you
chat for four minutes about something
and then you're done you have to
schedule everything
and that is not conducive to doing good
science
and being creative and and those kinds
of things so i think there's
definitely space where we crave that
spontaneous
in-person interaction but
those opportunities are not available to
everybody and we've also demonstrated
uh with these proofs of concept all of
the virtual conferences
etc the virtual connection is possible
and indeed
very uh beneficial to the scientific
community
so i really feel like these are
complementary that they
both fill different needs and that
neuromatch academy and virtual
conferences in general
are not going anywhere i think we're
going to keep doing that
but we're going to be and we're going to
appreciate the in-person stuff all the
more
for it and then we're we're going to
continue doing those in-person things
when it really makes more sense to do it
that way
i love the optimism and i completely
agree with you i miss the random
collisions most of all you know
maybe i was meant to be born as a
molecule on the fluid
adrian did you want to tag on sure i
mean the thing that's really changed for
me that i really hope
uh continues after the pandemic is the
opportunity to give talks
in places that you either you know
logistically it would just be you know
too much
to do or you know generally generally
one just doesn't have the time to do
everything so i mean during the pandemic
i've given more
talks to high school students than i've
ever given in the rest of my career
because i can you know instead of it
being hours or days of my time which you
know
it's hard to to make available i
you know i just pop into my study i can
zoom anywhere else in the world and i
can give a talk to high school students
which is great
so public outreach and and just reaching
other people is excellent
and earning the confidence is also true
i've also
seen some of the best talks uh
by the you know the the biggest stars in
science
since the pandemic because they may not
necessarily come to london ontario where
i'm based but of course they'll jump on
zoom and
they'll give a talk so i hope that
aspect of this continues long after the
pandemic because it's
some of the opportunities have been you
know really tremendous although i i also
miss the face-to-face
stuff but some of the the online
opportunities have been incredible i
think
it really does speak to the
democratization of science we were
talking about earlier
and accessibility very targeted question
for you adrian i see we're running out
of time
does it matter if your sleep is broken
up you said i need eight hours can i
have four hours then get up for a couple
hours another four hours or do i need
eight hours and a block
i wish you hadn't asked me that
so i'm not going to answer it very
directly because that actually that's
part of the data we're now
still looking at i mean we ended up with
this massive data set
as i say more than 10 000 people that
reported a lot of information about
their sleep and this is a question
that came up really frequently from the
participants you know
we would ask them how much sleep they
had and they would immediately write and
say hang on
you know i'm a i'm a young parent and i
i get eight hours a day but it's in
blocks of two hours you know what does
that mean
uh and of course there are many
variations of this there are there are
shift workers uh there are people that
only work at night there are people that
have young children are up in the night
and all sorts of things so
this is something that we're looking at
at the moment and i i don't have an
answer for you but it's going to be
super interesting thanks adrian megan
last question for you
if you were to give advice to someone
who wanted to do something like neural
match
what would the one piece of advice be
it's going to be a lot more work than
you think but it's totally worth it
i know that's kind of a throwaway answer
but it's very true
like it's neuromatch the the academy
started with this idea that we could
just make some videos and put them up
online and it would be great
and it turned into this massive
undertaking that um
was vastly beyond anything that we ever
anticipated
um being capable of as a group in that
short amount of time
we started in may and by july we
launched this school
and so it's it's a lot more work than
you think and there's a lot more nuances
and better make sure that you have some
you know corporate infrastructure in
place that also helps
um but it's totally worth it and you
will meet amazing people along the way
i thought that answer was perfect it was
honest but optimistic
unfortunately this is all the time we
have for today i'd like to thank all of
you in the audience for joining us
and special thanks to adrian and megan
for sharing your
insights and optimism with us please
visit our website cfar.ca to find out
more about this series and to view
recordings of previous talks
the recording of this talk will be
posted early next week
thank you again
[Music]
you